richard sherman reportedly opened to
signing with
the seattle
seahawks and according to nfl media the
seattle seahawks reportedly opened to
a reunion
this one has many layers and levels that
i investigated last night i mean on the
surface setting aside any other
potential motivations that we will talk
about fully and completely
does it make sense at this stage of
richard sherman's career to want to go
to the seahawks does it make sense for
the seahawks to want him back after
three years with another team i think
that's a good question i mean
one i would say it does make sense from
richard sherman's standpoint i do think
there that makes sense you know i think
he's kind of found out that the market
is not quite what he was expecting for
his services i think he's kind of hit
that reality so
i i don't think there's any team he's
going to turn down at this point i don't
think that's going to happen i think
he's open to anything like please sign
me somebody give me the money somewhere
near the ballpark of what i want
now they're still running that same
defensive scheme and when healthy you
know richard sherman's good he's good
you know the super bowl gear threw
everybody's perception out of whack you
know everybody was ranking them again as
one of the top corners in football and
all of that and that was that was
ridiculous he was real he was real good
not great and he wasn't one of the five
best corners in football that year no he
can't sit there and play man-to-man
against the best receivers in football
at this point of his career but he can
bring something to that secondary i mean
when healthy like i said there's still a
lot of good play there and you know
they're they're a team that you look at
them and you go
corner is an issue for their football
team all together they have a real need
there now it's just like mike where i
think you're hinting at
do they want to deal with all the other
stuff i don't know i i don't know what's
that relationship like
how close are russell wilson and richard
sherman i i don't know that's that's all
things that kind of like percolated
through my brain when i heard these type
of things
well and that was my first thought i
mean we know it's well documented that
there was acrimony at times between
richard sherman and russell wilson and
we have to rewind to 2012 when wilson
shows up as a third round draft pick
becomes the starting quarterback
there is natural resentment of a guy who
does that and who has that vibe of
company man and go hawks we've said this
before there were veterans back in those
days that would mock him behind his back
for go hawks they would say it in a
high-pitched voice behind his back
um you know he
in any workplace there's the one guy who
is so good his mere presence makes
others look bad yeah and there is
natural resentment of that guy that's
the way the world works and that's who
russell wilson was early in his career
and then you fast forward to 2014
season
super bowl 49 early 2015
marshawn lynch battering ram down near
the goal line game on the line chance to
repeat as champions
what do they do
instead of running the ball they call
for a pass as marshawn lynch said on
turkish tv he doesn't like to talk about
that story very much but he did talk
about it on turkish tv he thought that
hey super bowl mvp face of sports in
america somebody didn't want me to be
that
so russell wilson throws the ball it
gets intercepted by malcolm butler and
that becomes
something that players on that team
certain players on that team could never
get over and richard sherman was one of
them and 2017
right when after that season ended it
was time to purge all of the russell
wilson i don't want to say haters but
they made it russell wilson's team
and and and i i'm told that one of the
reasons that they're not slamming the
door on this it's a little bit of a hey
russell you know
yeah you don't run the show around here
two can play at this game yeah yeah and
again and and we we we insulated you
from guys like this we ran off guys like
this to make it your team and now you're
gonna do this publicly well maybe it
won't be your team anymore maybe we'll
bring back one of the guys who wasn't
afraid to say you effing suck when he
intercepted a pass that you threw in
practice which richard sherman did and
he's admitted to saying that yeah
i mean you you said a lot of true things
there you know yeah i mean one yes i do
think there was some resentment towards
russell wilson when he first got in the
door because
yeah everyone kind of went google and
gaga over it you know remember when he
got drafted whoa third round pick and oh
quarterbacks this short don't get
drafted they can't be successful i mean
he was a little bit of a lightning rod
topic there and then of course he starts
as a rookie and he did some good things
as a rookie
and i and and that was
you know again we've talked about this
so many times
where
there a lot of the guys on the team a
little bit or can have you know
resentment towards the quarterback
anyways because it becomes all the
attention about him
so that does annoy certain guys in the
locker room let alone i think a team
like that that had really strong
personalities especially on the
defensive side of the ball and i think
they were sitting there going wait like
russell's good we get it but this team
is like
seattle legion of boom the defense is
what's making this thing go i mean
russell wilson didn't have to do a whole
lot for them to win that first super
bowl if you can remember and not to take
anything away from that but i'm sure
that led to that let alone russell
wilson is not yeah he's not your typical
hey let's come over and hang out i'm
going to barbecue and we're going to
play video games and drink beers and do
all of that kind of stuff i don't think
he's that type of guy either so he
doesn't welcome himself to the locker
room that way and there's nothing wrong
with that i mean you don't have to be
that to be a successful quarterback but
uh i think it did add to that and then
the super bowl thing on top of it mike
you're right i think there's some of
that there too let alone i think daryl
bevel was trying to make a point too
about like hey look i'm a great
offensive coordinator and i want to be a
head coach and all that so i think that
all played into it and uh this is
interesting i it's slowly going to turn
this year to not russell wilson's i mean
i just feel like it's over this is the
last year maybe this still gets traded
around the draft time i don't know but i
just feel like it's over there in
seattle
source familiar with the dynamics told
me that ultimately the belief is the
seahawks won't sign richard sherman
because
they won't be able to pay him what he
wants yeah i can't see that that's what
it all comes down to he's going to have
a number in mind that he's not going to
deviate from he doesn't have an agent to
tell him hey if you want to play this
year you're going to have to soften your
expectations and chris i'll go back to
something that i've said multiple times
if robert saul is not at the front of
the line to sign richard sherman to help
him implement his defense and create a
positive impression on young players
that are going to be learning that
system and just be his guy be my eyes
and ears be my lieutenant in the locker
room if he's not at the front of the
line to sign him
what does that tell you what does that
tell you he's been his defensive
coordinator the last three years his
entire time in san francisco
the mere fact that the jets haven't been
mentioned even mentioned as a
destination should tell any other team
something right i don't know why i'm
choosing my words carefully i guess i
don't want to get in any twitter fights
with richard sherman today or any day
yeah but the fact but this would apply
to anybody look i mean
solomon thomas was available and and
robert salad didn't make a beeline for
him i just think that that those things
are telling when you have a coach who's
trying to implement the best way he can
his system in a new place and he's got
guys that he just coached that he just
worked with whose efforts helped him get
that job
and he's not rushing to bring them with
him i think that i think that tells us
something well i i i don't disagree with
you i'm not going to say i totally agree
with you there i think you're right in
some aspects i do think too you know
sometimes when you're a new coach like
robert solo 2
he wants its defense to create its own
identity and some of these guys to step
up to be the next richard sherman
knowing that a richard sherman might
only be around for a year or two and hey
he's a strong personality he's a star in
the league you know so he's one of those
guys too that you know they could feel
if you're a new coach you could be like
he could kind of squash the
personalities of some of the other guys
we have in the secondary who are young
and up-and-coming leaders and doing that
type of stuff but i think also your
point is very real too mike and really
you can go farther than that i mean come
on how many damn seattle coaches are
around the league coaching defenses
right now i mean with dallas dan quinn's
there we don't hear them talking about
him you know i know he did go visit the
raiders and did all of that but did he
visit the range i thought he went there
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm wrong no bruce
maybe
i don't know why i thought maybe he
visited there at one point earlier there
was a connection to the saints there was
a connection to the saints because of
chris richard but that kind of came and
went right right so i mean i think i
think once he found out what the saints
had budgeted
that went yes and uh you know again this
current market i just can't imagine
him getting much more than i don't know
four or five million dollars maybe not
even that at this point you know you
haven't played a lot of football in two
of the last three years and the one year
yes was good but as we explained already
come on i mean that was like a
remarkable defense that year by the
49ers it was one of the better pass
rushes we've seen it was a better pass
rush than the the the seahawks had
during the legion of boom i mean that
was up there with like the broncos of
2015 type pass rush what the 49ers had
that year so that makes life easier at
corner too um so i i yeah i think it's
gonna be one of those where he waits a
while and finally realizes it and then a
team goes okay here and he he kind of
just comes to the realization
realization
i've danced around this before but i'm
just going to go ahead and say it it was
my understanding heading into the 2019
season where he did have the rebirth
fueled by the pass rush was second team
all-pro was a pro bowler unlocked
millions in incentives under the
contract he negotiated for himself going
into the 2018 season it's my
understanding if jason verret had stayed
healthy jason verrett was signed to
replace richard sherman and sherman was
going to be gone before week one i don't
expect you to say anything because you
know kyle shanahan but it's my
understanding from people other than you
that for rat was brought in so they
could move on from richard sherman after
one season they were ready to move on
after one season and then he had the big
season in 2019 they kept him for 2020
and richard's always been the one who
said
this is over this is over i'm moving on
and moving on and the 49ers haven't said
anything the 49ers are not unhappy for
him to move on and i'll leave it at that
mike i you know yeah
i've heard the same things you have and
i can say that because i i didn't hear
them from the 49ers i know you know i i
know other people in the league and
things like that so i just don't put you
in the back i know i hear you because
everyone's going to think you got it
from i can't say anything about them
with them thinking that and i i i try to
tell everybody all the time like the guy
tells me nothing about his football team
it's it's really rare that we even talk
about that and especially this time of
the year when hey his life is important
and he's trying to figure out a lot of
things he doesn't want to tell me johnny
big mouth tv guy
that's not going to happen but i i heard
from
say you know some some some people in
the league those same type of rumors
there that yeah if a rat didn't get hurt
that richard sherman could have been in
trouble there's no doubt
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports